so yeah I don't support Peter files
rapists serial killers no way they
refraction the prison population I saw
people in prison was society's most
vulnerable people people with addiction
issues soldiers more than half of my
friends were soldiers congrat him war
yeah PTSD come back from Wars no help
from the government just used and abused
get on street drugs to self-medicate and
end up in prison and you know they don't
give a [ __ ] about them they come to get
them to do their dirty work sometime
after the Middle East they come back
messed up in the head and then they end
up in prison
you got 20-plus soldiers day right now
committing suicide in your country right
absolutely absolutely ridiculous and so
writing and still fighting the
government just to get the just to get
the VA to pay for some of them there's
guys that have Agent Orange from Vietnam
that still are fighting the government
to get them to pay for their treatment
and and they're losing yeah terrific
and the craziest part about that is
there's still it's amazing that there's
any sense of patriotism even within
these veterans that are fighting the
country to pay for the [ __ ] they've gone
through because they know you know
there's always a new generation that
they can brainwash that's what they rely
on they just rely on young idealistic
people pump them up with patriotic
notions and send them off as cannon
fodder yeah so prison is the biggest
house after mentally ill when they shut
down the mental hospitals after Cuckoo's
Nest came out prisoners by default
became the biggest house of the mentally
ill like I said earlier a third of them
couldn't even read or write and III
started to listen to the stories ninety
percent were injecting heroin now people
think alright filthy heroin addicts they
don't deserve anything to come with the
earth stealing stuff well I had to break
through doubt and listen to the stories
and they were they were sexually
molested as kids they've seen their
parents die they didn't even have
parents frottage thrown away
to the streets kicked out other houses
or they've been abused previously and
then what are they gonna do to fend for
themselves getting no help from anyone
they get in with the gangs that get on
the drugs and they taking the heroin
because heroin is so strong it puts them
so far out of their minds they don't
have to think about all the abuse and
the horrors that they've suffered
because no one's give them the tools to
deal with them so you've got human
beings being were housed for profits in
America for the private prisons and the
contractor in the tens of millions in
year and then the kick bounce to the
politicians and the legislators are in
the tens of millions a year in political
contributions they're paying these guys
after tighten laws it's put more people
in prison so they can make more profits
that's why America has got one in a
hundred adults in prison right now it's
ridiculous that's why this social unrest
you know III the police have got arrest
quotas I heard a policeman say I go in a
black neighborhood and make my arrest
it's like shooting fish in a barrel
right they're gonna make so many arrests
they just go or they can arrest
low-level drug users are the easiest
ones but the put on the news they're you
know they're arresting Pablo Escobar's
[ __ ] so hard to rescue a drug
trafficker the low-hanging fruit or the
the low-level drug users the street
level people so all this social and rush
you got going on around the world right
now is a reaction to the extreme the
prison system has gone in America and
the drug laws and the war on drugs if
you're a black guy walking around your
neighborhood got some weed on you cop
might pull you over not just brush your
weed but might shoot you dead right this
is all functions of war on drugs so you
know all all drugs should be legalized
taking you know kids should be educated
and not incarcerated that's my
philosophy what what is the perspective
from your area of the world on what's
going I mean I know what's going on
globally right now but we've gone out in
the street and we've seen you know you
got people you've got two sides of the
street one of them are all Trump
supporters or they call themselves back
the blue where they're supporting the
police and you have the other side of
the street that's black lives matter
it's 50/50 white people and black people
on the black lives matter and the people
that are
on the other side saying we back the
police we support the blue Trump 2020 it
seems like it's way older of a
generation and it doesn't matter what
the truth is about anything it's just
they're stuck in their ideologies and
it's just this primal instinct they want
to it's they just want to fight it's so
wild seeing it in real life so anyways I
was just interested to hear the point of
view from someone like you living in
your part of the world well my point of
view is this you know I read over a
thousand books in just under six years I
become obsessed of history philosophy
psychology
yeah and technology advances but human
nature remains the same so for a while
history people have always formed groups
and then these groups will brutalize or
go to war with other groups of people
call it religion politics race anything
you want you could fix the race problem
and people would find another way to
form groups to attack other people hmm
in the jail it was the white gang the
black gang the Mexican gang the
mexican-american gang and whichever
group was strongest that the most
numbers would brutalize the groups with
the least numbers and that's a microcosm
of society yeah it sounds like it really
relates back to prison right I mean that
seems like a very boiled down version of
what the broad spectrum is in the world
well the racial position that you know
America became politically correct but
it passed it bypassed the prison system
it's been in there from them for the
last decade and it's not changed and if
you can keep the prisoners divided like
that you can conquer and control them
and if the elites can keep the
population divided that I can conquer
and control them so that's what I
believe is so divide and conquer yeah I
mean you can clearly see that the right
the right wing conservatives they signal
they called a signal to the white
working-class and the big businesses
like oil and the left
nose to the colored working the brown
and black working class and elite level
like Silicon Valley but it seems like if
the two working classes work together
the majority of power would be there
yeah yeah there you go and you've got
the police they were from the working
class policing the working class so the
working class is policing itself how
clever is that if you're running a
country right right
the problem here depressions are run on
prison labor if all the prisoners
refused to work the prison's would
collapse mm-hmm because they can use
prison labor as a slaves slavery was not
abolished in America there was a
loophole in the Constitution slavery is
abolished except for people convicted of
crimes so not only are they using the
prisoners as slave labor force to run
the prison system all the major
companies in America are using that
slave labor force as well everything
from military equipment to road signs
all these contracts that they do it's
just one big financial state them
[Music]
[Laughter]